[Musique]
c'est un festival de théâtre et de
musique qui a lieu aux Mesnil du 22 au
25 septembre dans le parc des minutes
sous chapiteau
elle est très éclectique il y a des
spectacles pour enfants il y a des
spectacles tout public il y a deux
spectacles cette année autour de la
famille les vitres Swan le samedi soir
et baron une maison de famille le
dimanche après-midi voilà
et puis il y a des lectures il y aura
entre autres Swan Arnaud Damien Bonnard
et Marie Kaufman qui liront trahison de
Pinter le samedi en fin d'après-midi
il faut venir parce que ça va être un
festival très sympathique il y a une
guinguette on peut manger sur place
et on va voir des choses
assez surprenantes c'est une
programmation qui voilà qui fait qui
fait la part belle à des auteurs
contemporains des choses qu'on n'a pas
forcément l'habitude de voir
[Musique]